INVESTORS NERVOUS BECAUSE HIGHER
RATES MAKE BORROWING MORE
EXPENSIVE.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
U.S. UP IN COURT JUSTICES ARE
TONIGHT CONSIDERING A MAJOR CASE
THAT COULD AFFECT UNION WORKERS
NATIONWIDE.
"FOX NEWS @ NIGHT" ANCHOR
SHANNON BREAM HAS SPECIFICS.
>> FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE IS RIGHT TO
CHOICE.
>> ILLINOIS PUBLIC EMPLOYEE SAYS
FROM THE TIME A UNION FEE WAS
DEDUCTED FROM HIS FIRST PAYCHECK
HE'S NEVER HAD THE RIGHT TO SAY
YES OR NO.
TO HAVING THE UNION REPRESENT
HIM.
HE SAID HE IS NOT AGAINST UNIONS
BUT HE IS OPPOSED TO BEING
FORCED TO UNDERWRITE THEIR
POLITICAL SPEECH.
JUSTICE KENNEDY PUT IT THIS WAY.
"WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS COMPEL
JUSTIFICATION AND COMPELLED
SUBSIDIZATION OF A PRIVATE PARTY
THAT EXPRESSES POLITICAL VIEWS
CONSTANTLY."
FOR DECADES, THE HIGH COURT HAS
DEBATED HOW BEST TO HANDLE UNION
FEES FOR WORKERS WHO DO BENEFIT
FROM THE ORGANIZATIONS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING EFFORTS
BUT WHO DO NOT WANT TO LEND
SUPPORT TO THEIR POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES.
JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR WERE SUGGESTED
SOMETIMES PART OF THE BARGAIN.
>> WE COMPEL PEOPLE TO PAY BAR
ASSOCIATION FEES.
THEY CAN SAY THEY DON'T TAKE THE
SAME POSITION AN POLICY
QUESTION.
ANY UNION MEMBERS FREE TO GET UP
PUBLICLY AND UNDERSTANDING TO
SAY THEY DON'T AGREE WITH THE
POSITION THE UNION IS TAKING.
AS FOR THE POTENTIAL IMPACT ON
MILLIONS OF UNIONIZED GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES, BOTH SIDES ADMITTED
MEMBERSHIP WOULD LIKELY DROP IF
THE UNION LOSES THE CASE.
WITH CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
NOTING UNIONS WOULD HAVE TO WORK
HARDER TO MAKE THEIR CASE.
IT'S A HEATED ISSUE PITTING THE
GOVERNOR AND ATTORNEY GENERAL ON
OPPOSITE SIDES.
>> WHEN A UNION BOSS CAN GIVE
CAMPAIGN CASH TO GET AN A
POLITICIAN ELECTED AND SIT
ACROSS THE TABLE FROM THEM AFTER
THEY ARE ELECTED AND NEGOTIATE
TERMS, THAT'S A CONFLICT.
>> THIS CASE IS NOT ABOUT
IMPINGING ON ANYBODY'S
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THE LAW ALREADY PROTECTS
PEOPLE'S FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
THIS IS A CASE WHERE THERE ARE A
SMALL GROUP OF WELL-FUNDED RIGHT
WING EXTREMISTS THAT WANT TO
ELIMINATE UNIONS.
>> EIGHT OF THE NINE JUSTICES
HAVE VOTED ON SIMILAR CASES.
THEY WERE SPLIT EVENLY.
THERE IS AN ENORMOUS FOCUS ON
THE NEWEST MEMBER ON THE BENCH,
JUSTICE NEIL GORSUCH.
NORMALLY CHATTY AND ENGAGED.
TODAY HE DID NOT SAY A WORD.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT.
>> Bret: MIKE MENTIONED THE
DACA SITUATION.
THEY WANT THIS TO BE IRONED OUT.
>> NO RULING ON THE MERITS TODAY
>> NO RULING ON THE MERITS TODA
TODAY.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY WANT THE